good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 2086 object
class Keter special containment
procedures news reports in all major
towns and cities are to be monitored for
missing persons that had recently or
regularly used public transport agents
are to be dispatched to high-threat
regions on a semi-regular basis all
recently discovered a CP 2086 colonies
are to be condemned and demolished with
chemical explosives standard media
suppression tactics are to be applied
during this entire procedure as of this
writing 5 specimens of SCP 2086 are in
foundation custody all specimens are
stored in what had previously been an
aircraft hangar because of their short
lifespans and high reproduction rates
the number of SCP 2086
instances in foundation custody shifts
regularly terminated specimens formerly
in fundation custody are to be moved to
a specialized cold storage container at
site or study
description SCP 2086 is a species of
arthropod that resembles various makes
models and brandings of public transport
vehicles typically buses mature SCP 2086
instances weigh approximately 17,000
kilograms
although this number can greatly vary
juveniles typically weigh less than 200
kilograms a newborn specimen of SCP 2086
can be expected to grow to full size
within one week on average SCP 2086
specimens live 12 to 15 days with
females producing up to 20 offspring
after reaching reproduction age at
approximately eight days mature
instances of scp-2006 do not feed
instead living off nutrients consumed as
juveniles
however only mature incidences of SCP
2086 display foraging behaviors when
foraging SCP 2086 are almost
indistinguishable from standard
automobiles
although closer examinations reveal the
steel wood plastic and glass to be a
specialized form of chitin vital organs
such as the heart brain and stomach are
stored beneath the flooring of a CP 2086
is inner chamber a human corpse
preserved in a shellac like substance
typically serves as the decoy driver of
wild SCP 2086
instances fibrous appendages protrude
into the corpse SCP 2086
instances use these fibers to manipulate
the corpse providing a more lifelike
appearance SCP 2086 instances can
unravel their roofs into wings that are
capable of lifting the entire organism
in flight which is their standard method
of locomotion when not foraging in
addition the wheels can unravel into
long grey or black legs while the
headlights appear to serve as
bioluminescent optical organs the
appendages of a CP 2086 instances are
abnormally apt at fine manipulation when
compared to other species of arthropod
specimens have been observed building
crude shelters with materials located at
nesting grounds SCP 2086 typically
nested abandoned junk and scrap yards
juvenile instances in the wild have been
observed removing bus stops signposts
and relocating them typically in a route
that leads back to the local colony
accidental civilian observation of SCP
2086 instances engaging in this activity
is minimized
due to the significantly smaller size of
juvenile specimens the mature instances
of scp-2006 will drive along the route
laid by juveniles picking up human
passengers once a significant number of
humans board an instance of scp-2006 the
organism will release a substance
similar to chloroform to incapacitate
its prey upon returning to the colony
juvenile SCP 2086
instances will enter the mature
instances internal chamber each
passenger is then forcefully removed
from the mature instance by a juvenile
the juvenile SCP 2086 instance will
proceed to force the human through a
sphincter located under their hood
linking to where the steering wheel and
driver's seat is typically located in
mature specimens once consumed hairlike
appendages attached to the driver's seat
will pierce the trapped human's body
these appendages service feeding tubes
draining blood from the prey once the
prey has been drained of blood the
feeding tubes will begin to secrete a
saline solution into the corpse the
internal compartment will then begin to
fill with a shellac like substance
preserving the corpse okay I don't think
I'll ever look at my car in the same way
again
thank you very much for listening if
indeed you still are and you are all
dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Muslim Mookie slump god Justin day
John reporter captain Gorge fluffy dread
my archive curator neck tie verbal Kody
tench cheese whip depp's McGee and
oblong dish boy if you would like a
special Thank You the end of each of my
videos and some other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
volgen thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]